in supporting the humble address i'd
like to echo
the remarks made by the prime minister
and
on behalf of my own party to come
together today
in appreciation of a life well-lived
a life of service and of duty
a life that shaped modern britain and
provided much needed stability
to our national story
my thoughts first and foremost are with
her majesty the queen and the royal
family
prince philip was a man of many titles
duke of edinburgh lord high admiral
a royal commander baron of greenwich
but above all he was a much-loved father
grandfather and great-grandfather
to her majesty the queen he was not only
her
beloved husband he was in her words
her strength and stay for seven decades
so it's right that today this house and
the country
comes together to pay tribute not just
to a man but to the virtues he
personified
and to his ceaseless optimism about the
country
britain can be and what the british
people
can achieve the life of prince philip
was extraordinary lived in a century on
fast forward
a time that saw world war
a cold war the fall of empire
20 prime ministers the invention of the
television
the internet artificial intelligence
and technology so extraordinary it might
have seemed
to a lesser person as if from another
world
throughout that time the monarchy has
been the one
institution for which the faith of the
british people
has never faltered and as we've seen
once again
in recent days the royal family has a
connection with the british people that
runs
as deep today as it did when philip
mountbatten
married the then princess elizabeth in
1947
that is not by chance it reflects the
quiet virtues
the discipline and the sacrifices
we commemorate today
my own connection to the duke of
edinburgh began
long before i entered this place like
millions of other children
aged 14 i started the duke of edinburgh
awards scheme the dmv
as we called it my first activity was to
volunteer
at a local mental health hospital where
unbeknown to me at the time my late
grandad
would later be admitted and my final
activity
was wandering around dartmoor in a small
team
with a compass and a map in the pouring
rain frantically trying to find our way
mr speaker if that doesn't prepare you
for coming into politics
nothing will and in
in recent days i've been struck by the
countless stories of lives
turned around by the dv awards
young people who found their confidence
and found their way this was summed up
by a 14 year old girl who said
on passing her bronze award that she
felt
i can do anything now the dmv now covers
130 countries
and has helped millions of people around
the world it is perhaps the best symbol
of the duke's global legacy
he was of course also patron to more
than 800 charities and organizations
he was the first president of the world
wildlife fund
he was the patron of the british heart
foundation
he was president of bafta and he was
chancellor of the universities of
cambridge edinburgh salford
and wales he carried out as has already
been said
staggering more than 22 000 solo
engagements
and countless others alongside her
majesty
the queen the duke will also be
remembered for his unstinting support of
our armed forces
it was in dartmouth in 1940 that he
graduated as a naval cadet
and as the prime minister has described
went on to a distinguished naval career
today mr speaker the british armed
forces mourn
one of their greatest champions
the duke was a funny engaging
warm and loving man he loved to
paint his work has been described
characteristically as
totally direct no hanging about strong
colors
vigorous brush strokes
he was also a great lover of political
cartoons
and not something the prime minister and
i can say that often
although i saw a cartoon this weekend
that i think captured this moment of
national and personal loss
perfectly it depicted her majesty
dressed in black looking back at her
shadow
and seeing the duke standing there
as ever at her side attentive
and holding her hand
mr speaker britain will not be the same
in his absence
for most of us there's never been a time
when the duke of edinburgh was not
present
at every stage of our national story for
the last
seven decades he's been there
a symbol of the nation we hope to be at
our best
a source of stability a rock
her majesty once said grief
is the price we pay for love
the duke loved this country
and britain loved him in return
that is why we grieve today
but we must also celebrate him
a life lived in strong and vigorous
brush strokes like his painting
and we offer up this tribute
to the duke of edinburgh for a lifetime
of public service
the gold award